hey it's me again in this video we're
going to talk about evaluation this is
another example of how to evaluate
evaluation means to analyze the data to
find a reason why something is occurring
so this is a 71 year old female she gave
me all her data and we're going to go
through each piece of data and just kind
of go up and down and see if we can make
sense out of it see if it relates see if
it associates for a reason of finding
the root cause typically the mistake of
evaluation is to treat effects
individually and not try to understand
the effects so number one she cranks
sweets that could come from a low
potassium that can come from an insulin
problem many things but here's number
two drinks one and a half gallon of milk
a week so that kind of jumps out that's
a lot of milk she drinks so I know we
have a urinary frequency that can come
from menopausal symptoms it can also
come from other things which I'll get to
spider veins that is a it's a vitamin C
deficiency but you can't fix it by
taking ascorbic acid that's what people
think is vitamin C that's just the
antioxidant portion you have to have the
whole vitamin C complex especially the
Val flavonoids okay so that's because
mouth applauds that's part of the
vitamin-c complex helps to maintain the
integrity of the vessel and the collagen
but we'll come back to that okay
takes vitamin D and calcium probably
because she has osteoporosis but she has
bone pain here history of kidney stones
that's a calcium issue it could be other
things too a pH issue bright lights
bother her that is a vitamin A
deficiency so again I'm kind of thinking
out loud as we go through this feet fall
asleep right that can be peripheral
neuropathy that's like a diabetic thing
with a lot of insulin issues or it could
be a circulation issue and there's other
causes as well and then anxiety
osteoporosis high blood pressure okay
hot flashes night sweats mood swings
hysterectomy 1995 fibroids and then
she's pear shape so this is estrogen
stiffness and terrible sleep so so
here's the first thing when I do I'm
going to scan and kind of see if two of
these or more of these start connecting
one of the things that stands out is
this milk thing right here now that's a
lot of calcium so she's getting a ton of
calcium
she's taking calcium okay and vitamin D
increases the absorption of calcium by
22 times so it increases calcium in the
blood okay and then but she still has
osteoporosis all right now one of the
symptoms of falling asleep or numbness
in the feet is something called hyper
calcium what does that mean it means a
lot of calcium in the blood too much
calcium in the blood so now this one
does relate to high calcium that's
interesting so that's one thing that it
could be more associated with because
this aligns with that now taking vitamin
D and calcium that also aligns with too
much calcium anxiety is another symptom
of hyper calcium high blood pressure now
that could come from many things could
be adrenal but let's pretend that
there's high calcium in the arteries
well what the guts that that's going to
do is going to calcify the arteries
arterial sclerosis clocking in the
arteries boom that relates to
hypercalcemia urinary frequency would
also relate to hypercalcemia kidney
stones will relate to hypercalcemia okay
so now one thing about hypercalcemia
there's high calcium in the blood but it
doesn't mean that it's going into the
bone so of course she has osteoporosis
because it's not being directly to the
bone but bone pain is a symptom of
hypercalcemia you could look it up so
here's what I'm seeing that she's having
she has a lot too much calcium when you
take vitamin D and I didn't ask her how
much she's taking but if she's taking a
lot about him indeed a lot of calcium
she's going to get symptoms of heart
problems because that calcium is going
to plug everything up what what she's
missing and what kind of stands out for
me is something to direct the calcium
into the bone and that's vitamin k2 so
vitamin k2 is what I see that she's
missing the most of one thing I noticed
that I didn't write down here is she's
honest she's been on a low-fat diet for
years well guess what vitamin k2 is it's
a fat soluble vitamin it comes from
butter grass-fed butter breast fed
cheese grass-fed chickens with the egg
yolk grass-fed beef so k2 is what she's
missing so that's one thing that I'm
gonna probably recommend to start taking
this immediately and stop drinking this
milk and the calcium start taking the k2
to start to drive all this calcium into
the bone from the blood into the bone
that's the most important thing that she
needs help with now vitamin k2 also is a
fat side of vitamin so the other thing
that I would probably want to get more
data on
is number two does she have a
gallbladder does she have enough bile
because another thing that's in the back
of my mind if she has bright light
problems like at night that's a vitamin
A deficiency that's the fats I have a
vitamin so I'm like why does she have
that that's I don't know why that is so
I started asking about the gallbladder
she has enough bile because it could be
if she doesn't have enough bile that's
could be why she's not absorbing any
fats I have a vitamin especially if
she's been in a history of a low fat
diet so we might want to give her little
bile salts to absorb the vitamin fats I
the vitamins and get the k2 in there so
she can start to drive out this calcium
and then work with her doctor that
adjust this medication because if she
didn't have calcium the arteries the
blood pressures going to come down the
bones will start getting solid these
symptoms will start improving so that's
the thing that's the most important
hot flashes night sweats mood swings now
this is interesting she's had these
symptoms since 1975 after she had the
fiber right out so the other thing that
I'm thinking the fibroid if we take it
back earlier vibrates are a tumor and
tumors grow with various hormones that
are called anabolic hormones they make
things grow too the hormones is estrogen
and insulin so I would probably ask her
history of your diet if it was like a
lot of sugar in the past if it wasn't I
would ask her about estrogen and I
already know based on her history that
she's been on premarin which is an
estrogen replacement for many many many
years
okay so that's probably why she has the
fibroid and then she removed it let's
see when you take out when you do a
hysterectomy
you have a backup organ that has to then
do double the work and that's the
adrenals so these symptoms are really
adrenal related so she really has two
issues that have to be dealt with but
this stuff here if supported with the
adrenal support those will probably
improve and then of course the
pear-shaped that's an estrogen thing and
then one last thing well two things one
is stiffness well that's that's calcium
in the in the soft tissues terrible
sleep well if you're not going to get
calcium you're not going to be able to
relax again that like everything here
aligns with this one problem so that's
pretty much how I died weight and how
other people should evaluate and not
just jump and start treating everything
separately all right so I'll see you in
the next video